it's june 1st
2021 so it's time for another monthly
update video in which i'll talk about
what went on in may and what you might
have missed all of this is linked to
below if you
click the show more the video
description you'll see links to all of
these sorts of things
and we'll also talk about what we've got
coming up in june a lot of cool events
on the horizon talk about three big
things that i want to highlight for
all of you viewers subscribers people
that are interested in what i'm doing so
big thing number one
i've got a new class out with listenable
called basics of stoic philosophy and
practice which
you can listen to for free for seven
days if you want to
link is right below you can see it in
the video description
and check it out it's uh pretty cool
even if you
know a lot about stoicism you might
learn a few things
big thing number two back in april i
started a new medium publication called
practical
rationality to aggregate my writings
there
i'm doing more writing there and i'll be
you know
writing quite a bit this coming month so
if you want to see my longer form stuff
that
is the place to go big thing number
three and this is something i might want
a little bit of
viewer suggestions about i'm starting a
new kind of podcast
episode a shorter podcast episode
that'll
springboard off of a passage from a
philosophical text and talk about the
key idea
and how you can apply it in your life
why it would matter for you
these are going to be shorter than my
usual podcast episodes
i don't have a good name for this yet
i'm kicking around some ideas
so i'll talk about that in the june
section but you might want to
you know think about what those could be
called
what went on in may well you know first
of all
i finished up with my academic classes
for
spring i had quite a few still extending
into may either in terms of grading
or in terms of the work that i was doing
i also got back to the gym
for the first time in 14 months and
really felt it the first week and then
it got better
after that been doing some writing i'm
getting prepped for my summer classes
one of which is actually starting this
coming weekend and i as i mentioned
released that class basics of stoic
philosophy and practice with listenable
i'm very proud of that it's an audio
class
it's got 12 short that means anywhere
from
you know three and a half to ten minute
lessons and you can learn all about you
know some key
ideas practices people
texts all sorts of cool things about
stoicism so you might want to check that
out i had quite a few events
in addition to my usual you know worlds
of speculative fiction and
ama and half hour hegel and all that
sort of stuff i
also participated in stoic on x military
and gave a short talk linked to below
about the nature of genuine courage
which is a really
important topic in stoicism that a lot
of people
get mixed up about especially within
professions like the military so that
was a
clarificatory thing but it's useful for
anybody in any walk of life
as i mentioned we did do our worlds of
speculative fiction we
finished with our scott backers prince
of nothing trilogy looking at the last
book the thousand-fold thought
i had quite a few people after that
saying can you go on and do the next
four books in the series and i said well
we just devoted a quarter of the year to
our scott backer we do have to get to
some other
writers as well so maybe down the line
sometime we'll we'll see ama might ask
me anything a lot of good questions
a lot of good discussions hopefully some
good answers
i also did a political theory and
practice discussion
focused specifically on one of the most
controversial topics within aristotle's
works
the notion of natural slavery and
masters
long story short aristotle actually does
think that most slavery is against
nature immoral
unjust but he does hold out some some
room for
natural slavery and that got abused by
slaveholders in the new world
as well as in other places so you may
want to check that out we had a really
great
discussion there it didn't get veer off
into any bad directions with trolls or
anything like that
we also had our classic metal class with
scott tarrouli
this time we talked about german heavy
metal
from the 1970s into the mid 80s so of
course the scorpions except but
all sorts of other bands as well that
you might not have heard of and some
cool things
about the scene as well as some
philosophical implications rudolf
schenckner
talks about the scorpions being
motivated by a philosophy of friendship
so if that's intriguing you
you want to go check that class session
out we had our half hour hegel
q a and discussion sessions both the
public and the
patreon exclusive one i did my
philosophy chat for my patreon
supporters
as well and we did two shows of the
wisdom for
life show that's a radio show that i do
here locally
and you can catch it in podcast form you
can get it in video form
and see dan my co-host and i recording
we talked about some really cool
topics this time around and um
what else i did i did two events with my
wife
andy shaka on the platform clubhouse
which is audio only
and at this point in time is is apple
phone iphone only
not android unfortunately but
really cool conversations that we had
about different things we don't record
them
so you know you want to get in on those
when they're actually
happening one of the cool things is not
recording it right
what else is uh going on that i should
talk about
in in in may well i did a lot of podcast
work some of you may have seen me
releasing the episodes on
uh franz kafka's in the penal colony
uh or michelle foucault's technologies
of the self or
julian the emperor slash julian the
apostit
oration vi to the uneducated cynics
right
all of that stuff was released but i've
also been releasing
uh episodes on plato's symposium a whole
sequence running through the entire work
of
what is arguably one of the greatest
works of western literature
ever written so that's all in the
sadler's lectures podcast
uh videos i i did quite a few you know
the event videos from
stoic on x military worlds of
speculative fiction the ama
the political theory the classic metal
class the
wisdom for life shows all of those i
managed to get three half hour hegel
videos done this month and released to
my patreon supporters not yet to the
public
you'll see those coming out this month i
also did
a caption contest video that was quite
interesting and i did a video
on aleister mcintyre and my
connections with him and how he's
influenced my thought in
in that series on philosophical um
uh commitments and and uh phases and
stuff like that
developments and people seem to really
like that so that that's pretty cool
um i've also been remastering my
epictetus
and coridian videos where i apply that
half hour hegel
approach you know doing a very close
reading line by line
of epictetus's zen coridian so if you if
you miss those you might want to go back
if you're interested
in a classic stoic text i did a sadler's
stories
about my my cats that i used to have a
long time ago and how
their mother gave them to me as when
they were kittens and i got one book
review done
of a book history of anger which i gave
a kind of mixed review to
what else core concept videos you might
have seen the
gilda lou's videos
on bartleby or the formula and a lot of
people
got into those so that's what went on in
may all right what is coming up now
in the month of june well a lot of
things going on
i'm going to continue going back to the
gym i've got as i mentioned
two academic classes one from milwaukee
area technical college
starting this weekend another one
starting later
in in june for milwaukee institute of
art and design i'll talk a little bit
more about that one i think
in just a bit because that that one's a
little bit
you know the matc one is right out of
the box ethics class
the other one's a really cool intro to
philosophy class that i'm doing
but let's talk about events first right
so
there's another stoic on x coming up on
the
fifth that is this saturday all times
that i'm giving here
are in central time so you want to check
your
your uh time zones right at 11
15 my wife andy shaka and i will be
doing a joint presentation
as part of the stoicon x women
conference paths to flourishing that
goes on all day but we're doing
our presentation at 11 15 a.m so if you
want to get in on that and hear it then
you
definitely want to
you know register for it link is below
you can check it out
later on just a little bit later on that
day that that is the fifth
at 12 p.m central time i'll be doing my
monthly ama that is ask me anything
session so you may want to get in on
that
on the 9th at 5 p.m i'll have my hegel
q a and discussion session which i offer
thanks to the patronage of my half-hour
hegel
project supporters it's open to the
public so
you don't have to actually have red
hegel's phenomenology in order to
participate it's up to you to
pop in and we'll talk some hegel or
german idealism or philosophy in general
then on the 10th we'll be doing another
clubhouse at 1pm
my wife and i andy shaka it's called
greg and andy ramble on
so we can talk about just about anything
and we never know who's going to show up
so
check that out if you've got clubhouse
on the
12th we will be shifting to a new author
and new series for worlds of speculative
fiction
these books right here which by the way
somebody gifted me
for my 50th birthday last year we're
looking at the
world of tears series
and these are six novels they're all
pretty short you know less than 200
pages
since this entire volume is 544 we're
doing
oh this is about volume two we're doing
volume one
uh this time around actually i think
that one's even shorter
440 so these are a quick read
uh really great very influential within
the world of
sci-fi and fantasy you definitely want
to read them
and you definitely want to join me for
the event which will be happening
on the 12th at starting at 12 p.m we
start with a video premiere
and then after that we have a zoom
session for some more
in-depth you know in-depth conversation
about the
works on the 19th
at 12 p.m we'll be having classic metal
class we haven't yet decided what the
topic is going to be
for this month i've got to talk with
scott about what we want to delve into
do we want to do more music history
or something much more philosophically
focused or
something else also on the 19th at 2 p.m
i'll be doing my
philosophy chat with patreon supporters
definitely want to become
a patreon supporter it's available at a
certain tier
of support the 21st
through the 23rd i am going to be
virtually at the aristotle and
aristotelian tradition conference hosted
at marquette
just down the road from me and it's
going to be me
and my my good friend and colleague
harold covley presenting a paper
on pro races as a cause
in aristotle epictetus
alexander of aphrodisias and simplicia
so
some pretty high-powered metaphysics and
philosophy action
there on our part on the 24th
at 1pm we will be having another
clubhouse that's andy and i
rambling on and on the 24th again
at 6 p.m milwaukee stoic fellowship we
are going to be discussing
cicero's conception of the four roles or
characters or personae
a really cool thing to talk about and
then finally on the 27th
that's a sunday at 12 p.m we'll be doing
the next political theory and practice
discussion
that is going to be on theodore
dostoevsky's
grand inquisitor chapter of the brothers
caramazo so if you're interested in that
sort of thing you definitely want to pop
in for that
i'm still going to be doing some more um
video
work right i want to get my my half hour
hegels cranked out and also release
those to the public i've got a lot of
books
yet to review i'm going to do some more
personal
videos probably some sadler's stories uh
another
philosophical development and commitment
one
i think probably on philosophy as a way
of life
we'll do another caption contest that we
just
actually started back in maine maybe
we'll do another one for june
as well and you should you should uh
well core concept videos
i'm going to be doing mills on liberty
in part because i'm teaching that
coming up in the intro to philosophy
class
i've also got some videos i need to
shoot on foucause the subject in power
and we'll see what other core concept
stuff i can get done i should talk a
little bit about
the the intro class but let me first
tell you about another video that i'm
going to be releasing fairly shortly
so i mentioned the basics of stoic
philosophy and practice class i'm going
to shoot a video
specifically about that telling people
what in broad strokes what's in that
class
and then they can get an idea of whether
they want to check out listenable
or not but i okay so going back to the
intro class i'm
doing something a little bit innovative
this time instead of just trying to do
like let's you know hit on the main
areas of philosophy and compress all
this into
six weeks you know these these students
of mine
at my ad are artists and designers
they're not going to be philosophy
majors but i could turn them into
philosophy junkies who are going to keep
doing lifelong learning and that's the
goal
of the class is to get them
hooked and offer them resources so we're
going to do a lot of stuff that i don't
ordinarily do for example we're going to
talk about trolley problems quite a bit
and we're going to read
philip a foot and and you know judith
thompson's pieces and we're going to
look at memes about it and discuss that
sort of stuff
i'm kicking around using john wisdom's
article gods
and the university discussion that took
place in philosophy of religion we're
doing mills
on liberty to talk about lifestyle and
you know
um the marketplace of ideas and free
speech
we'll be doing a lot of other stuff like
that as well so i'm not quite sure what
else i might shoot on that but there's
going to be a lot of cool stuff
coming out the last thing i suppose i
should talk about is podcasts
so as i mentioned i'm trying to do a new
kind of podcast
i'll be doing episodes you know like my
normal podcast
and then on the side i'm going to do
these shorter episodes as well that i'm
going to record here
and those are going to be designed
primarily to be
like things that somebody can pick up
and use right away to help themselves
out to apply philosophy
within their their ordinary day and life
and relationships and all of that and i
still don't have a good name for it i
thought about sadler's snippets but i
don't really like that or sadler's
shorts
i'm not really that sold on that either
most of the cool names are already taken
for that sort of thing
so i got i got to come up with an idea
for it but anyway stay tuned
there will be some of those things
coming out
i'm also going to be continuing on with
the sequence on plato's symposium
we are about halfway through at this
point
and after that i'm going to be doing
podcast episodes that i need for my
ethics class on wd writes
wd ross's sorry the right and the good
um plato's republic book two the part
about you know the ring of gaijins and
and ego some video not videos convert
some videos into podcast episodes on
iran because i use her
in my classes so that's probably going
to be a little controversial people be
wondering of i become an
objectivist because that always comes up
whenever i do any rand stuff the answer
is no i'm just using it as teaching
tools in my class
that's pretty much it for the month but
it already sounds pretty packed
again those three big things if you want
to get in on them
new class listenable basics of stoic
philosophy and practice
check out my medium where i'm going to
be doing a lot more long-form writing
and then we've got those short podcast
episodes coming up hope you can join me
at some of these
online events and i'll see you in the
month ahead hope you have a great
month and finish out the first half of
2021 way better than we
we did the first half of 2020.
you